20e nouveau voyage sans passeport en
compagnie de roger tellier
ça y est
aujourd'hui nous sommes et nous
commençons je crois que j'étais gay para
las palmas oui nous sommes ici à las
palmas qui est important dans ce port
passe des navires en provenance de
quatre continents une route maritime
pour l'amérique du sud pour l'afrique et
pour l'europe
cette ville offre le double intérêt
d'une ville ancienne usine moderne
les rues sont parsemées de jardin et des
ath abuse des curieux qui vont de la
peine d oye oye fourni avec un appareil
seulement donné par les scénarios sont
les planteurs de bananes et les
producteurs d'oeufs
tomates c'est le chauffeur qui est tout
à gauche c'est surtout du côté gauche
oui ce sont des voitures importées de
l'auteur certainement arriver c'est
inquiétant c'est gênant pour le vider
pour dire pour certainement pas dans
l'habitude mais là toute l'année dès la
sortie d'astana soyez nous trouvons des
bananeraies petits dessins sont assez
petits oui parce que on les coupe d'une
hauteur de deux mètres carrés cause des
vents alizés
pas du tout c'est balagne et produisent
toute l'année et on entretient
constamment celui-ci est encore en
fleurs d'autres sont à maturité
c'est qu'ils ont une très jolie fleur
elle est rouge
voyez la culture en étage vaut environ
las palmas avec les bassins pour
l'irrigation
qu'est-ce que l'on transporte la con
transport de la canne à sucre la sécu
salignac la femme excessive aux tiges
ces images horribles ont été prises au
mois de janvier mais les routes sont
bordées de géraniums sauvage
sa voix un européen qui arrive en hiver
la marge je veux dire contraste assez
curieux
si ce sont également les environnements
ce spa canyon en amérique mais d'etarras
20 et qui s'appelle ans pour les cas
derrière le bar en cô oui un moment
important dans des abris ou des cultes y
voyez vous un étage aussi des tomates
déjà sur le bord des routes
ne vous restait toujours des cactées
mais cette fois ci c'est sa voix d'une
petite maison d'un cultivateur non loin
même nous arrivons au centre de l'île
oui nous sommes qu'à 60 kilowatts heure
las palmas mais c'est un parador sa part
adore ou ses navires à nantes
c'est un hôtel national m ça c'est des
lieux du week-end des gens de la grande
canarie
oui c'est aussi à leur peau pour les
touristes se fera taire et à 2000 mètres
d'altitude
même beaucoup de soupe aux montées de
troupeaux là nous arrivons dans le sud
déjà nous sommes à 12 km du mans enfin
les effets dans ont dit que c'était elle
continue en miniature et moi je dirais
pas que c'est une planète en miniature
comme angers c'était sur un rayon de
50km voyez vous nous avons nous
rencontrons de telles choses différentes
sur cinq ans sur cinq ans il a mené la
cité est à peu près ronde et à 50 km de
diamètre
là nous sommes à 12 kilomètres des
hautes montagnes nous sommes dans un
désert est un tout petit peu plus au sud
à quelques kilomètres nous rentrons les
chameaux ce qui nous rappelle l'afrique
fort bien
c'est depuis lors un petit bout comme ça
sur un chemin là nous sommes au sud de
l'île tout à fait au sud dans l'oasis de
maspalomas et là on ne retrouve alors
des paysages vraiment les paysages
africains et les voyous des plages des
plages des mers du sud ont rencontré le
mans il ya même eu ou en bas l'appareil
bon j'aime vraiment les trains ter s'est
amusé d'abord là dedans ce qu'il a fait
sans plus grande librairie
ça c'est vraiment des rivages
dans cette ville la température qu'il
fait en été bâtie de rédac simone et en
hiver 14 degrés pour moi vraiment très
bonne très bonne et pas mal fréquenté
par trop bête méchant hors du tout c'est
très peu de touristes ailleurs le
rechercher des sites de montagne et la
lorelei nous survolons l'île de tenerife
suite à peine une demi heure d'avion de
la gontrie et dana reeve là nous sommes
à santa cruz de tenerife
ici c'est une île aux mille aspects de
ce poisson pélagique le moment
des solutions parce que par easy money
et voilà le port de la même ville de
santa cruz en effet on al impression
lorsqu'on en norvège alors oui si ça
fonctionne on pensait aussi on peut voir
des pavillons de la nation différente et
la coule abondamment vie et
naturellement kanari's la production et
la banane tous prêtés sans aller jusqu'à
nombreux rangements et oui on trouve
tous - mixte en ce moment je pense
d'elle pour la france sujet du port soit
7000 tonnes par an dès cet automne par
et pour les fêtes c'est pas mal aussi je
pense certainement parce que j'ai une
grosse production et où des camions à
longueur de journée pour michael elle
porte ouverte sûrement hectares à bertry
pour être mûri soit pendant le transport
mais généralement c'est pas des pourris
à destination et aujourd'hui
c'est toute la journée néanmoins cette
journée ils sont gentils gentils des
gens sont très accueillants 6
approfondissez vos soirées où le travail
de leur chargement de bananes une soirée
en beauté la wii c'est assez curieux
c'est un autre endroit de l'île
c'est paulette russe appelle ça rappelle
pleine bataille en effet pour le dire
ces images ont été prises à
perros-guirec par exemple on était à
seulement des mâles plastique qu'elle a
rien qui rappelle beaucoup ces villes
pour bien le dire mais des neiges
presque éternel oui
les dentelles ah oui la dentelle c'est
une production de tenerife nous croyons
beaucoup de monde sur mon honneur ça
c'est à travers cet intérieur de si l'un
c'est l'autre à terre liste au centre
d'habitat train ter qui agace km de
diamètre
l'aspect lunaire qui perpétuellement
balayé par les vents et c'est ce qui a
donné naissance à ces monolithes que
l'on voit les ans sur tout
et au centre de ce faire vous allez voir
graphique du tijd il ya de 1800 m
d'altitude une cathédrale
et oui vous savez produit par les vents
et un certain moment c'était vraiment un
océan de scories
l'envolée lyrique vous parlait lui a
droit en accusateurs gratuitement et
termine son épaisseur de neige éternelle
blanc ou l'inversé les vampires ont
dessiné ces étrangers pour m
c'est tellement de pouce on a vraiment
l'impression d'être sur une autre
planète
bientôt peut-être un dab sont
certainement prochainement
espérons le où la lave couler du vent la
mer et on descendait d'immenses blocs de
là pour se concerter en vue
et s'ils se rappellent qu'il est
probablement responsable des mines
oui je veux dire que l archipel des
canaries s'était formée par un groupe de
sept volcan sous marin c'est ça du
sommet de votre corps soumah voilà nous
sommes dans une autre il c'est dans un
rock celle de la plus proche du
continent africain il ya beaucoup de
petits hommes et quelques chameaux dans
cette idée sur furieuse
il n'y a pas d'eau avant on était quand
même des récoltes abondantes simplement
fait non c'est une ville très rarement
ses côtés d'alan il ya des cendres qui
les garde l'humidité de la nuit qui
commande et voici comment ils avaient
dit qu'ils apportent du continent il ya
bien même pas de source
c'est à manger les minorités c'est une
idée formidable
environ 300 trains ter et un jeu vous
c'est vraiment un désert dollars
c'est une chose ordinaire et même à
quelques kilomètres de cet endroit
puisque d espagne à l'appel des
montagnes de fuego
où voyez vous pour le touriste on creuse
un trou d'un mètre on jette à papier
dedans et en quelques a failli somme la
température et 409 riche prospère parce
qu'il ya des maisons qui sont assez
accueillante dans ces désherbants
ce soir c'est là vous voyez on laboure
la lave
ils sont descendants sont ça rend fou ce
soit ça pousse jusqu'à la mer les des
blocs de la retenue et produire des yeux
eric chevallier a proposé de réaliser
avec le concours de roger payer et de sa
langue ses peines
c'est nathalie de mauvais montage tir
michel rues sont animées d'illustration
sonore 2009